[Music]
yeah so got a crazy story for you guys
so you might have seen the app wordle
recently have you guys seen it yeah your
time just bought it you play yeah so new
york times just bought it but about two
weeks ago one of my friends he's a great
mobile app developer bootstrapper
he basically was like oh wordle is going
viral and there's no mobile app that
everyone's using so like the wordle guy
had put out this crazy story he put out
this story about how he was pure he
didn't want to monetize it it was just a
toy for his girlfriend it went viral out
of nowhere which i don't know if i
believe because he works at mischief and
like i'm not sure i totally buy that
story uh
but that was a story to the media so my
friend was like holy [__] there's a huge
opportunity for someone to build the
mobile app uh this guy doesn't own the
trademark of the name uh it's kind of
like ripped off an old game show so my
friend built an app over the weekend
called it wordle the app uh
went viral so basically like over the
weekend got like 30 000 organic
downloads was top of the app store and
my friend's one of these guys who likes
to build in public so he tweets
everything he always has he used to like
put his portfolio up so you could see
everything he's doing and
sam by the way this is this is gonna
support your build and public thesis uh
by the way this is like the perfect case
study of why of how you feel about
building public which is i like it in
theory it's like the face tattoo thing
right i like that other people do it
i don't want to do it and here's why
here's the cautionary tale like when you
know when the dare officer brings like
you know someone who's like been in jail
for drugs to the class
before and after of meth
like it's like
sean explain what wordle is because all
i know i don't play word games i play
real sports and so uh
i'm not i'm not trying i don't waste my
time with that so
when
when people are what is this game
it's a game okay so this it's a simple
game you you literally if you just the
way i get to it you just google wordle
first link you click it and it's just
five um empty
like letters like five squares where you
gotta guess guess a word
there's no clues it's not like a
crossword
it's literally just like guess guess a
word so you type in a word you might
type in like i always start with irate
because darmesh from hubspot
said the word irate has three vowels
plus the letter t plus the letter r so
you're getting a lot of common letters
there so it's a great start word so you
type that that word in and then it'll
tell you either it'll either show up
gray which means the letter's not in the
word yellow which means it's in the word
but you got it in the wrong spot or
green which is this is the right letter
in the right spot and then you have i
think five or six guesses to be able to
um
to get the word in the end and then the
beauty of it is at the end it's like you
got it you feel the sense of
accomplishment the whole thing takes you
like
two minutes to play the game so it's
like really easy to play in that sense
and then if you get it right it lets you
share that you got it right but it
doesn't share what the word was it
shares like the like imagine what you're
looking at now which is like the word
and all these colors but take the
letters off it just shows the colors so
it'll show somebody else oh man i
started off not having any of the
letters then i got the t at the end then
i got one letter at the end so that's
what that's like fourth one i got it
right so that's why you see that grid of
green uh squares posted on twitter and
it started going viral on twitter and
again and what what's like the score
okay so i'm sorry i just got it moist
and did you really just play that are
you watching a video
i think i heard you this morning i was
trying to just do like an illustration
you know just trying to get some
accurate b-roll all right so i
understand so people have been sharing
this like crazy and darmesh the founder
of hubspot he plays a daily and he even
built a competitor to it as well and so
your buddy ben levy what's what's this
guy's name his name's zach shakheed
and what's the name of the app
it was called wordle the app so part of
the story basically so he goes and
builds its app uh he tweets like holy
[__] this is the fastest growing app
i've ever built you know i've built 10
other businesses they've all done really
well but this is the only one that's
like growing organically like crazy
uh and he basically the wordle creator
sees it and he's like yo
uh he gets on the phone with them he
calls him and he's like hey this just
doesn't feel the way by the way this
whole thing's just happening in a
twitter thread ben sends me the first
tweet he's like yo zack's uh because
i've met zach through ben he's like yo
zach actually cloned wordle next tweet
look at this [__] he's tweeted out a
graph it's going crazy third tweet um
someone someone says dude you just
ripped off wordle like you're gonna get
whatever suit or something and you know
you don't know the trademark for this he
goes what trademark and so i'm seeing
the tweets
in real time and he's bragging
he's bragging about how good it's doing
and he's like ha like there was no app
now i'm dominating this i'm getting all
these free free downloads this is
amazing he's just tweeting update after
update okay so ben pick it back up so
then somehow the world guy gets in touch
with it so the wordle guy dm's him and
he's like yo let's get on the phone and
my friend zach is like hey like you
don't own the trademark i know nobody
owns it there's a bunch of other apps
called wordle before this uh but like
let's partner or something and the guy's
like uh i don't like you know he
basically said some version of like i
don't do this for money this is just fun
uh you know ironically he sells the new
york times like a week later but that's
separate so my friend gets off the phone
with him uh and he's like all right i'm
going to talk to a lawyer i'm going to
figure out what i should do like clearly
there's no ability for us to work
together here uh and then like 20
minutes later some big tech reporter
dunks on him pretty aggressively and
he's like dunks on who your buddy or the
original creature jumps on zach my
friend and he's like
uh he basically says something like wow
like app developer has no ethics clones
wordle bragging about how he's at the
top of the app store uh and then you
know when that happens everyone goes and
looks at zach's past tweets and he
ironically had two tweets so like six
months ago he tweeted i hate app clones
like someone's cloning my app and i'm
gonna like come you know he basically
like disputed every app that was cloning
his old app and put posted a big threat
about how app clones are the shittiest
people didn't he call them like scumbags
or something yeah he was like there's
the scums of the earth that you're
copying my app uh
and then
wait you said you said the word ironic
so was he being serious
no he was being serious it was ironic
that he tweeted that and then he was
doing you know and then he was being
opportunistic uh
and then he also tweeted like
at the beginning of the year i have two
goals for j for 2022. it's like be more
vulgar
and make 10 million dollars this year
uh
so he just gets like proceeded to get
dunked on really aggressively and people
start buying his domain and or like you
know i'm gonna start like i'm gonna
dispute every app you've ever made i'm
like gonna make sure that everyone knows
you're the worst of the worst uh and
like
so basically that's what happens apple
ends up pulling down every single word
he calls you right somewhere in the
middle here he calls you for some advice
right yeah so he calls me in the middle
of this and he goes hey this is crazy
like app is doing really well i think
this is a big business like you know i
know bait i know how much these apps
convert like free to paid this is just
growing organically this is a 10 to 100
million dollar mobile app here what
would you do
and i was like well i think you know
ethically i'm not sure i think you did
kind of copy him but i get that like
this is version one and you're gonna
make it better uh like i could buy that
uh
but right now you're probably stuck like
the mob has you uh but he's like well
maybe there's a trumpian version to this
where like you know i kind of own that
like this is my approach and like i'm
doing it there's no change apologize
apologize
uh put up the white flag take it away
right these are options on the table
right i can just say sorry i did wrong i
could say
you know
sorry i said what i said and i'm gonna
make these i'm gonna change the name i'm
gonna make some concessions
and then there was go full trump and
full trump was like
just lean into it and yeah but you could
do that and then back down in a non like
douche way what you could say is um
yeah like look we're not claiming to be
innovators here but we are we're
executors and so we find things that are
great and we make them available for the
masses sue me
like you know that's like the way that
you could take this that's what that's
what
racket internet says they go we're not
innovators we're executors we're
operators
so how did the conversation go ben when
you guys talked about these options yeah
so basically i was like you know i think
those three options are on the table and
he was like yeah but i don't think you
know i don't think we're really doing
anything wrong like you know yeah there
is no mobile app uh so like while people
can think that i think it's fine so he
basically was like i'm going to double
down you know i'm by the way this other
guy didn't create wordle there was like
you're saying there was a game show back
in the day that was the same game he
created a web version of it is that
right because i think that changes it
too which is yeah this guy also copied
this show right like and it looks like
this guy zach did he
re do the app but call it word love
well that that's later in the story
that's like after wordle got shut down
in the app store he recreated a new you
know another word game uh let's
literally just shut down all the clones
yeah they shut down everyone that was
using the name wordle after that uh and
to clarify yeah there was there was a
game show that wordle was based on and i
think the guy's story was like i did
this for my girlfriend it wasn't for
profit so he didn't get crucified for it
so and what did apple say why did they
say they could just take down all these
things or you don't know you don't know
why they just there was no statement
they just took down every word a lap and
said you know you don't own this
trademark like you're being taken down
because we do decide what we do with you
yeah so
i'm i'm not a lawyer here obviously but
i've done some trademarky stuff and i'm
almost positive
that
someone's going to correct me but i'm
almost positive that even if you don't
own the trademark if you're like and you
can make the argument if you're like the
first or the most popular and if there's
like a general consensus that like yes
when people think of this name they
think of you
and these other clones or these other
people are trying to like steal
you know like uh act like they're you
the courts tend to favor your side even
if you don't own the trademark
yeah like yeah just because they don't
literally have that trademark there is
probably some like you know you would
probably win
yeah i think i think that's probably
true and like he he knew that uh like
there was some argument that there's
been other apps called wordle but it was
pretty clear that like they would have a
good case uh so he proceeds to kind of
double down on it gets dunked on
aggressively like basically you know he
doubles down a little bit like says like
no like this is based on the game show
you don't own a trademark i'm looking at
it now uh versions of that and then it
goes completely viral like 10th out you
know it gets like 10 000 people in the
tech twitter circle are dunking on him
there's an article
why why was his goal be more vulgar for
2020. why was that a goal that's such a
random you said that and
my mind is still wondering why was that
his name does that mean like be more
aggressive
i think he meant like be more aggressive
like when he sees opportunities be more
assertive and like you know be as
aggressive as possible when
opportunities present themselves uh okay
which clearly was what this was uh so he
went he went hard he got dunked on and
basically what happened was
uh people bought his dome people
squatted on his names zachsterked.com
they were like we're going to go vote
down every single app you own we're just
basically going to attack you
oh and so how's this
how's this end
so i mean basically it ended with him
shutting the app down as you'd expect
and now he's like making a new word game
uh because he likes the word game space
but i think his like when i was talking
to him about it earlier he was like you
know the biggest thing for me is
building in public is not always good
you know like the fact you know by
building in public like i just assumed i
you know this was great for me and this
is the really dark side of me building
in public well dude let's be more
specific he had 10 million dollars in
his hands
and decided that the tweet love
for
talking about what he was doing was
was worth that because if he just stayed
as an anonymous developer he just put it
under some shell company developer name
left it in the store didn't brag about
it it wouldn't have got picked up by
journalists as like the story isn't that
other people there are apps in the store
called wordle that are owned by
different people that's not the story
the story is
look at this guy
cloning this thing ripping it off
bragging about it and then getting [__]
on on twitter that's the story so if he
just didn't do that then that doesn't
get to apple like i think there's a
pretty good chance he gets away with it
because i know there's a the app store
is full of clones like flappy bird had
tons of clones every slot machine game
there's
people don't know this like random apps
like slot machine apps are what like
produces the most revenue in the in the
app store and um
and you know nobody really cares about
it they're under these like random
building company names because you don't
talk about it you're just crushing it
you shut up
yeah it's when you're not crushing it
that you want to talk about it as soon
as you start crushing it
yes when you're doing well you only talk
about it when you're not doing that well
or when you are doing so well that you
think that like you know
you can't catch up that's why people are
always like why don't you talk about
your e-commerce thing like why it's
working what do i need what do i need to
tell you guys about it for yeah
and i also think but transparency like
yeah cool i favor transparency uh with
people i trust not strangers on the
internet like i don't value transparency
well it's like if it's my wife or my
family or my co-workers all right i'll
give you transparency i don't owe you my
twitter follower or even my podcast
listener to tell you about every detail
i'll be very honest with you i tell
people things when it's beneficial to me
and i don't when i don't and i actually
recommend that strategy to anybody
there is no like a force that is there's
nobody forcing you to tell everybody
everything uh when there's no gain to be
had for you
yeah and there's actually clear
downsides and this guy just totally
screwed it up if you should have shut up
you just got to shut up sometimes and
that's really hard this it's the
building and public thing man and also
it impacted the wordle guy now he got
all this competition and he had a lot of
stress i think that like when you're
doing well you just shut up you don't
talk about it
you know i think you know part of it
becomes your identity like i'm the
building public guy so like i do
everything in public
uh and i think he was just like you know
type of guy that's like i'm a really
good at growth and i'm really good at
building apps and
wanted some love for it you know and by
the way i recommend this guy's blog or
sub stack because he actually uh he does
a good job of building in public like he
uh ben what was the one that we were we
were reading and i remember telling you
i was like dude this guy's stuff is
actually really good he had like no
followers but like uh or like you know
not no followers but he had a very small
following but i thought his content was
actually really interesting he would
talk about like all right i'm gonna
build this product because of this
reason so first thing i'm gonna do i'm
gonna go to you know lean domain search
i'm gonna get a name generator for this
okay i got the name boom now i'm gonna
go do this boom here's how i do this
boom all right i'm gonna fire up some
paid ads look here's the dashboard and
like he was
actually making progress so he wasn't
just like you know stuck in he wasn't
just talking theory like he was actually
getting users getting revenue
and he was very um again he was giving
out a ton of value and so i was like oh
cool i like to learn all this stuff
great thank you very much and uh in
those projects the trade probably worked
right he got interest and respect and
attention and he gave up you know just a
little bit of knowledge
uh but in this case it did not pay off
yeah and he like openly shares all of
his app numbers like that link i just
dropped zak dot so slash dashboard you
can see all of his app numbers all the
churn
uh so it's a big part of his identity
and he's really good at it but you know
sometimes it doesn't always pay to be
pop to build in public dude cornrows and
face tattoos it's cool that other people
do it but not for me
yeah the other thing is like identity be
real careful what your identity is
because your identity comes with like
you know some serious trade-offs people
have an identity and then they'll like
uh you know they use it to build a
little prison for themselves here's
here's my walls and chains that i put on
myself by like labeling myself in this
way
i like to i like people be like oh i
thought you said this the other day i'm
like yeah change my mind
speaking listen you know done speaking
of prisoners and building an identity i
saw that um someone did a survey like a
like a reputable source but i forget who
did a survey and they asked they did a
survey and they asked young folks gen z
who they follow for crypto and nft
advice and it was like i think they
surveyed hundreds of thousands of people
pomp was number one for the most trusted
person pomp is like our friend and
started out like just a guy on twitter
now he's like
pretty official how on earth does this
guy do so much so he's got a 200 000
person email list who he talks to i
think every day every day he's got a
daily business show and i think he has
like multiple hours of three hours it's
a professionally produced morning show
meaning like he's there on camera with
his brothers they had an agenda a
rundown of stories they're gonna cover
it's like a news show business news show
i think it's called the business news
show or some [__] like the best business
best business show um
and he does it for multiple hours
in the morning every morning and i think
i was with him and his wife a while ago
and she was joking she's like man he
writes all of it i don't know how he
does it but he writes really fast
how on earth does this guy have this
much output
i uh i have a tremendous amount of
respect for that because i know how hard
that is and i know there's there's not
usually people i look at and i say i
can't i couldn't do that and i know when
i look at that i couldn't do that um
there's no way i could maintain that
level of output um
at the same time
i would not want to do that that is not
a problem i want to build for myself i
don't think he's going to be able to
keep doing it he won't be able to
sustain that for more than two or three
years
yeah that's crazy his he's got like an
empire what do you what do you how big
is his empire you think you think he's
making more money from selling stuff as
opposed to actual bitcoin
we've speculated on this before so let's
i don't know if we we've kind of done
this before you want to do it again yeah
okay
okay fair enough so he's got a couple
components right he's got the paid sub
stack so he's got the free there's like
a free version of it but the daily one i
think goes to a paid group ben do you
know roughly what the paid size is i
think it's like i think it's something
like 70 000 people paying like 10 a
month or something like that i want to
say it's like 70k
uh ish so that would be what 700 000 um
by the way
the the i don't do public math that was
stolen from pom pom said that i thought
it was [__] hilarious and stole it
because i think it's amazing it's
amazing rule to live by
so he's got about 200 000 people total
on his list and he's got i think 70 that
are in the paid group so let's just call
it that then he's got a job board i
think the job board we had heard
either heard or we had kind of
investigated looked like he was doing
about a million dollars a year that's
cryptojobs.com or something so then he
said all right you learn about crypto
for me you want to work in crypto boom
uh he also has sponsors on all the new
on all the newsletters so at the end of
every newsletter it's like thanks to
these 10 companies he like rolls the
credits and if i had to guess that would
be
if he has 200 000 free subscribers that
would be around
between a hundred thousand two hundred
thousand dollars a month in sponsor
revenue
so we're at um
that i think i think what we've just
added up to is about two to two and a
half million dollars a year and then
that stuff the his videos he does about
a million dollars a year on his bitcoin
course
um which i don't think he even shows up
for or maybe he does but like i think i
think he's got teachers it's like pretty
automated um so let's add another
million there that's let's say three
three and a half million on the course
then there's uh investing so investing
is probably where the real money's to be
made very hard to say kind of what both
crypto investing so like buying bitcoin
and other tokens as well as investing in
companies that serve the crypto economy
that's kind of like and he had a fund
the fund was pretty big ben how big was
the fund uh but he closed he returned
hundreds of millions of dollars
100 no that that was the fund he was at
before though i think sorry his personal
fund which is like the pomp rolling fund
or whatever oh yeah i think was like 25
million a year or something like that
which is the equivalent of a 100 million
dollar fund
um so i think he was doing 20 to 25
million a year again these are all plus
or minus 50 percent and then youtube got
4 million views in the last 30 days and
then his podcast i bet is around where
we are but dude youtube at four million
views is uh that's like four thousand
dollars or something youtube pays like
nothing on just the views but maybe his
sponsors he's probably because i think
his best business show has a main
sponsor that's like uh yeah it's so fine
because one time i got in trouble
because i i disrespected them when they
were
they well they're not a sponsor anymore
right so can you tell the story yeah so
basically one time um the the hustle
wrote an article about sofi's ceo
getting in trouble for
i don't remember what it was sexual hurt
was it a sexual thing or was it fraud
something like that and he
in the headline we wrote so fine more
like so [__] and
they bailed as a sponsor and i told that
story on his podcast and he got really
uh he wasn't mad but uncomfortable yeah
i was like well you just tell him i said
it you know you didn't say it i said it
so so if i can't you're like a menace
yeah the sofa like marketing team so
like god everywhere we go this guy
comes in
so at this point i would say he's in the
huge range of
five and seven million a year just off
like pomp
that's income right they're not even
counting the sort of equity value that's
because there's also bitcoin pizza which
was his like uh ghost kitchen he
launched what else has there been he's
got merch is he a merch i think he's got
merch yeah he's got marge
what are the other part of his empire of
his uh his pomp empire he's got his
brother so he's that i really respect
that anybody who takes you know anybody
who's got the uh when i eat we all eat
mentality i respect that and he brought
his brothers along so one brother joe he
does awesome content about
the business of sports his other
brothers are his co-hosts for the best
business show because when i asked him i
was like dude why are you signing up to
do this morning show like there's so
much work to do youtube show every day
for multiple hours he's like yeah but
i'm just like it's me hanging out with
my brothers shooting [__] busting each
other's balls and talking business like
that's kind of what i would if i just
said what's my ideal life it's like i'll
just hang out with my brothers and like
you know like i mean i get it i can do
that the problem is like let's say you
want to take like a three week vacation
you know yeah there's a difference
between uh i like to do it and i have to
do it right and he's he's gonna have to
do it it seems like right now with where
uh you know you're committed to a
schedule um all right you want me to
tell you about an interesting company
yeah actually
one plug there so while ben's here so we
uh
i don't know when we're gonna talk about
the milk road i want to talk about my
new new new project that me and ben have
launched a new company uh but there is a
version of this which is the the one we
were like all right this is a great idea
but there's one drawback which is you
have to write this email every day and
it's the same thing it's a prison it's
like and we were very conscious about it
it's like ben you want to sign up for
this this is the prison we're going to
choose
uh to be in like if this is if this is
what we choose fine but let's not get
here and be surprised because uh because
that's the commitment we gotta make we
are every night and so ben at you know
midnight after the babies are asleep or
whatever it's like
you know he's like hey here's the draft
for tomorrow morning's email and then i
i was up until 2 a.m last night editing
the thing and so there's definitely a
pain in the ass component to it that's
uh you know
that i'm experiencing which is one-tenth
of what pomp does but it's more than
enough for me and you did the same thing
man it's hard i like i loved it i mean
it to me it it's like i think i told you
it's almost like running a marathon or
like being in a fight or something it's
like you're scared to do it you do it
and you get in the thick of it and you
like kind of enjoy it and then you get
you get to a point where you can take a
break and you're like this is horrible i
never want to do this again which is how
i felt like last year and then you get
like six months out and you're like
[__] i miss the i miss the action i need
to get i need to get into it
and so it's really hard to to write a
newsletter every single day to do any
type of content creation every single
day for more than a year is very very
very hard
really tough uh and we're only what
less than a month into it ben what's the
uh
where are you at in the grind like i
think we're giving it a year for like
how long you you could tolerate this and
and sustain this pace where are you at
right now you're only in month one
i'm at the still exciting still fun to
research and write but i am at the holy
[__] shawn's a way better writer than i
am point uh
but i'm still it's still fun
yeah sometimes i i i go into edit i'm
like let me just touch up this little
wordsmith and then like
i overhauled the whole thing because i'm
like oh no i think this could be better
and i'm like actually it was fine before
but like i just can't help myself like
last night actually this is an
interesting point to talk about at sam
actually so
so we should say two things one
we'll talk about what this company is
and why we started it basically every
year me and ben have started one company
um
last year's company was the e-commerce
company and we grew that from zero to
about 10 million in revenue profitably
uh and we and to do that like never had
done a physical product before
never like never knew how to get things
manufactured and all that
never had been spending like you know
200 000 a month on facebook ads and
being responsible for that return and
making sure you don't grow broke so so
that was the adventure last year this
year we were like what do we want to do
and we basically were like whatever it
is it's got to be in either crypto or
like kind of like teaching slash
audience building that's the stuff i
like to do crypto's like the topic me
and ben are obsessed with and that's why
we came up with this thing called the
milk road which is basically it's an
email you get every day and we just say
it's kind of like um
it's the way i got it's the way i got
good at crypto which was my buddy fer
khan who's way smarter than me
um he was like he you know he bought
ethereum and the crowd sale he bought he
was mining bitcoin back in the day like
this guy's just been ahead of the curve
on stuff
he's an engineer and every day he
basically just sends me like three links
he's like yo check this out you seen
this i'm always like no i haven't seen
it and then i'm always like wait what is
this why is this interesting and he's
like oh so the reason this is cool is
because abc and he just breaks it down
super simple for like a dumb ass like me
and i was like dude if i could just take
that idea
and
provide that like as a newsletter like
furcon doesn't care he's never going to
create a sub stack or a newsletter he's
like too smart and too cool for all that
[__] but i was like if i could take that
idea of like a smart friend just showing
you one or two cool things a day that's
going on in crypto and explaining it in
simple plain jane english
i think that that would actually be
useful how many subscribers do you guys
have
so we've been doing it for i think three
weeks now and we're at 16 and a half
thousand as of today so it's grown like
last week we're at 10 000 so this week
alone we've grown about fifty percent
what was the cause
two things we turned on uh paid ads and
so you referred or you have you know a
guy who uh is good with this stuff he's
been helping us out he's really good
actually like
wait i've tried like five agencies for
facebook as this guy's like better than
all of them how much are you spending to
acquire an email
um right i don't want to say that right
now but it's in the good range remember
when you were like dude back in the day
it used to be x now it's y we're getting
it for x still but we also aren't
spending a ton so maybe as we spend more
that's going to go down
um but honestly there's such a big
appetite for learning crypto because
people know people kind of know all
right this seems like the next big wave
like you know there was the internet
there was mobile phones there's iphone
and now like crypto seems to be the big
wave super hard to keep up with and i
know there's money to be made so i think
the appetite is there where i think
we're going to keep getting subscribers
for pretty cheap because
the appetite i've never seen an appetite
for content like this in my in my life
because i've been trying to make content
that people want and i'm always talking
about [__] i'm into and like you know
it's often like the name is good i think
the name's pretty good and you're using
that platform beehive is that any good
beehive's pretty good it's pretty new so
like there's a lot of features we need
where we're like yo we need to be able
to for example
if i um
do a partnership with somebody or what
or somebody plugs us in their newsletter
or let's say facebook ads we pay for
facebook ads i need to know
is that subscriber like
worth the same as an organics like are
they still opening it 20 days later you
know i need to know like
based on where they came from are they
still opening it to know where i should
put my energy spreading the word and so
they don't have features like that yet
but we're kind of working with them to
be like yo help us like good we need x
can you build it we'll be your best
customer
if you can kind of like help us uh get
what we need sick i think is i i think
it's going to work it just um
i think that
you'll start seeing well you've already
seen progress after one year you're
gonna see a lot of progress and then if
you continue to do it for three years
then [__] really starts to accumulate
the media really does compound
i didn't believe that it did compound
because i'm like well it's not like
subscription revenue necessarily but
then i realized like yeah but if i like
just continue doing this and i get known
you like it becomes it compounds in
terms of cultural relevance and that
usually translates to revenue
that's a good point and i've always said
this and i've always [__] this up
that's the reason i keep saying it as a
mostly as a reminder myself like the
best advice i get the advice i give the
most to others is the advice that i've
had this the lesson i've had to relearn
five times because i just can't like get
it through my thick head
and that's that what you work on and who
you work with matters way more than how
hard you work and put that another way
is the most important decision you make
is what project to work on
and so like i'll tell you like i've
worked on some really shitty projects
like uh we did a hackathon and we built
this app called beer hunt and it was
like
every time you drink a beer you like
take a picture of it you check it in
yeah but you don't give a [__] about
that
and it's like and people got excited why
because oh beer everybody loves to like
it would get a big reaction any time we
told somebody about it they'd laugh and
they'd they'd be like oh that's cool
i'll send it to my buddy or whatever
and so p people liked it who were
especially craft beer types but i wasn't
a craft beer type and also like
i didn't have the filter of like dude if
i'm gonna do anything it's gonna
basically take up all my time for like
three years minimum
is this the one right and um and i was
treating it like a you know like a
hookup and i should have been treating
it like marriage because projects are
more like marriage really when they like
once you decide to do them you're going
to do them for multiple years right like
and so
so i've chosen a bunch i did a sushi
restaurant horrible project beer app
horrible project tried to build the next
big social network and messaging app
worked so hard built cool [__] but like
the [__] hardest industry to like you
know you're just running around with a
bottle trying to catch lightning so my
project selection has been horrible to
date the best project i ever selected
was this podcast and then you know the
e-commerce one was okay not not great
like it's successful but it's more
successful just because i got better at
business it's still a really hard
business to be in and kind of a roll up
your sleeves type of business to do
i think this is probably the next best
like i think i finally did project
selection right and the reason why is
i think that crypto is as important as
like
you know mobile apps and iphone was in
kind of like 2009 2008 um 2010 maybe and
as important as like the internet was
back in like 1999
i think that's true and
when there's a huge wave happening it
kind of doesn't matter exactly what you
do you just need to make sure you're out
in the water paddling with your board
and
i had been kind of like i'd been
investing and thinking about it but like
it wasn't my job it wasn't my job to
think about it every single day what
this newsletter does like i don't know
if the news i don't know if the media
business is going to be amazing i think
it could be but even if it's not the
fact that my job is that every day i
have to learn two amazing things like
two interesting things about crypto and
be able to explain it to tens of
thousands of people
um
that is like that is a job that i think
is going to pay off in weird ways i
could think i think we're going to get
into good investments because people are
going to be like oh cool yeah you guys
got that big distribution yeah we want
you in this project yeah i mean i'm
going to find that's what happened with
the hustle
right and it's like i'm going to find
cool projects because i'm literally i
have to say something interesting
tomorrow morning at 7 am when this email
goes out uh i'm not going to say
something boring so that means i got to
learn something every day so that means
i'm turning myself into kind of like a
learning machine so
that is why i think this is the right
project and the reason i share this is
because
i think it's the most important decision
you make in any project you do in any
endeavor you do is just at the beginning
what project you decided to go go for
dude i i i that's wonderful i'm reading
three
two two books on this topic the first is
called wanting
um which is uh
andrew suggested it that's why i bought
it he suggested it on this pod it's
called wanting and it's about mesmic
desire um genetic
sorry memetic desire um and the second
one is the daily laws and this it's this
daily it's about uh the 48 laws of power
and mastery and all these great books by
this guy named robert greene but you
read just one page a day and the whole
first section that i'm continuing
reading is like how do you find what you
care about and it's really great because
the the the thing is is you want to find
you want to find stuff where you are
able to when you get into it you
actually get more energized and i've
done a lot of stuff like uh copywriting
stuff which i think is fun sometimes but
when i do it i'm like ugh i gotta like
i'll be like fine i'm gonna get this
done by one o'clock on monday i gotta
get this done and then i realized one
time a couple years ago i moved
apartments
and i remember the mover coming and i
planned for a week so i was like all
right we're gonna get all these box
we're gonna stack these box here this is
how we're gonna move it the move is
gonna come at eight o'clock i'm gonna be
there i'm gonna lift this up and then i
was i i got up at 5 00 a.m because i
couldn't go to i couldn't sleep i was
like i'm so excited to move and to like
physically move these things and set up
the new place and i was thinking about
that when i was figuring out what i'm
going to do next and that's one of the
reasons why i'm getting into short-term
rentals right now is because i just
got it and i think that the the point
i'm trying to make is when you're
thinking about what gives you energy it
doesn't have to be you said it but i
don't actually think you meant this this
way you said i think this is a big deal
and i don't think that's why it excites
you it excites you just because the the
i don't know why it excites you but like
the um literally just like it's a new
money that's kind of interesting i don't
think it would matter if like everyone's
talking about it or not like i i don't
know if you if that's what excites you
what excites you is like literally the
tiny minute details for some reason it's
it's just if maybe the math maybe like
you're over overthrowing the system
something about that is really
interesting to you right and so for me i
was like i just love moving these
[__] boxes and moving into a new
apartment i don't know why i love doing
that but like i love going out on the
street and hunting for places and
talking to the guy at the bar like what
do you think about this neighborhood are
all the hipsters moving here like i love
it i get obsessed with it and like i
what i was trying to do what i should do
next is i was thinking about what do i
just get so much energy of and i
remember i cannot sleep the day before
i've got to move because i'm so excited
that's so funny but i think most people
hate that but you love it which is why
it's even more valuable uh when the
thing you get energy from is things that
drain other people's energy like bingo
you're going to out-compete everybody
because for them it's going to be
working for you it's going to be play
like my co-worker this guy paul gemheim
told me this month he goes
he was like um i hadn't really thought
about this i was really young at the
time maybe 24 24 25.
and he goes
he goes yeah so you should um you should
go talk at this event and i was like why
is it gonna like
give growth to the to our app or like
are we gonna recruit people he's like no
you should go talk because you love
talking right like
he's like talking gives you energy so
you're gonna love it and i go what he
goes he goes yeah it's like um you know
for most people if they had to go give a
talk in front of a bunch of people
they would like they'd be drained by the
time they even get up on the stage and
then afterwards there'd just be like
finally some relief from the anxiety
i've been feeling he's like you're the
opposite he's like i noticed that he
goes he goes yeah he goes he goes it's
like going to the gym you know you go to
the gym and like if you just look at the
math it's like well there's a lot of
energy expended working out
but how do you feel after you work out
you feel yeah you feel physically a bit
tired but you feel like your actual
spirit feels energized uh like you go
give energy and somehow you get energy
in that moment and he's like so you know
there's some stuff that's energy drains
and even though it's not that taxing
it's like just thinking about your good
think about filing your taxes for like
the next 20 minutes watch you'll feel
[__] awful by the end of it you're
going to need a nap or a drink
and it's like on the other hand if you
do stuff that gives you energy you know
blah blah blah and so you know you can
audit your calendar and say i'm a
highlight in green the things that i do
that give me energy and put in red the
things that that suck my soul
and um and you know if i want to have a
better life i should probably just do
more of the green [__]
i think that's that's great i think that
my i i've talked to a ton of people
right now who are messing they're like
you know i've made a little bit of a
name for myself should i do it in my
career but like i don't even like it
what the [__] do i do and i'm like ah
yeah it's tough but you gotta find where
where
you have to find what gives you energy
that doesn't necessarily mean what makes
you happy by the way but what gives you
energy
totally because it can be really
challenging and frustrating at times and
you know uh
it'll have highs and lows in fact i i i
add this channel to every slack that i
do so like i just put it in our
e-commerce one because we just had like
a big low where we got effed over by
this like crazy unforeseen circumstances
like oh well here's another one and so
you know my team they get so bogged down
by these highs and lows
and i was like guys remember like we we
stood in line to get on a roller coaster
why are we surprised when there's highs
and lows that's what a roller coaster
does like if you didn't want the thrill
like you know we can go sit in the grass
over there we don't have to be on a
roller coaster line i'm stealing that
and it's like you know so i create a
slide channel called highs and lows and
i say well now we have a place to put it
which is in itself like therapy it's
like ah dude this is gonna be an epic
low that i put in there and we went we
wrote the low and then we started riding
some highs that we've had and like it
just
it's what you should expect don't be
surprised when the roller coaster goes
up and down when you you stood in line
to get on the roller coaster you were
excited about going on this roller
coaster um you know that's that's what
you wanted you wanted the adventure and
so um and so you know that's how i think
that's like a good tip for really any
business that's a great line with the
milk road which milk roads the name of
the the crypto email that me and ben
sent out every day um and like you you
go to milkroad.com i bought the domain
by the way for 2000 i think it's pretty
good pretty good buy right it's a good
buy two grand for milk that's a great
buy
we had milkroad.xyz and it was like
such [__] like people couldn't even
like the thing wouldn't even load i
don't know why but like milkgrove.com so
when we started writing this i was like
all right i found my thing now i found
my thing when i was probably like 32 or
something like that right so it took me
12 years maybe to figure out what's the
thing that gives me energy and mine was
i just want to get paid to be curious
and it's like what does that mean it's
like i don't know like ever like
every day i hear about different stuff
or reading about things i'm talking to
people wouldn't it be great if just like
going and learning that thing was
somehow how i got rich and fam richard
famous like wouldn't that be dope and
like the podcast does that it lets me
just be curious i can be like oh
someone's making a bunch of money
selling turnkey tailgates to
universities how does the economics of
that work right like that shouldn't be
something i'm i get to i get the license
to go spend three hours figuring out but
the podcast gives me that license and
cool it gives me money and fame for for
doing it i get power and influence great
uh as a byproduct then the second thing
the ecommerce one for example does not
give me this and that's why i don't
think long long term it's for me because
it's not me being professionally curious
it's like more of an opportunistic thing
milk road is that because every day i'm
like
i like for example yesterday this guy
came out with this thing i think you'll
find interesting
so most of the time people talk about
the prices people tell us about a lot of
time talk about price of crypto which is
kind of annoying once you stay in it for
a while but like let's say the price of
ethereum right now is about twenty six
hundred dollars per per each
and um
it should be five thousand
yeah people people come out and they
should be they're like oh like
ethan's going to five thousand is going
to ten thousand eath to the moon and
like
nine times out of ten this is you know
either hopes and dreams
or it's like just click bait like if i
say i think bitcoin's going to five
million a coin guess what that's going
to get covered by a bunch of people and
like a bunch of people are going to
share it because it's outlandish
and hey you know please don't hold me to
it what are you going to do i'm just
making some far-fetched prediction about
the future
and the last one is they are like using
some weak ass logic like like people do
this with bitcoin all the time they're
like there are 55 million millionaires
in the world and there's only 21 million
bitcoin there's not enough bitcoin for
the millionaires to all have one so
price is gonna go way way up and it's
like okay like i understand the general
idea of what you're saying but like
that's so unsophisticated compared to
and this is why like warren buffett
comes out and says
bitcoin is rat poison or it's pure
speculation there's no fundamentals that
was like the that's the common narrative
so what i thought was kind of cool was
um
was that um
ben just linked
an article in the chat where i did the
clickbait thing where i said i'm putting
25 of my net worth into bitcoin this is
like you know a year and a half ago or
something like that and i was like
because there's a there's a wave of
institutional capital coming in i'm
going to front run the wave and it just
sounds great and guess what like you
know these these
news websites you know look at this like
cringing
with my face with a big one what was the
thing that happened
all right so this guy came out he's a cr
he's like a kind of like a crypto quant
uh investor he's got like his own fund
or whatever
and he said
you know i actually think that there's a
way to value
ethereum like you would value any stock
any stock of a company he goes so how do
you value a company you value a company
based on its cash flows well guess what
ethereum has revenue so what's the
revenue of ethereum ethereum has revenue
because there's transaction fees
and um you know peop this is not new but
there's something new of like ethereum
changed what it does with the
transaction fees so now you can value it
so for example bitcoin has transaction
fees but the transaction fees get paid
to miners so as a bitcoin holder you
don't get that revenue and the miners
all have different expenses one guy's in
greenland his expenses are low because
the electricity is cheap there whatever
so you could never really get the
profits the net profits of bitcoin
transactions or the bitcoin network
because it really wasn't that's not
enough it wasn't it was apples to
oranges
but ethereum has changed what it does
with the fees which now lets you create
a valuation model so what happens all
right ethereum transaction happens let's
say it's a hundred dollars
for the transaction fee
um
70 of that it's called the base fee and
do you know what they do with the base
fee you know where that goes no i don't
know anything what you're talking about
to be honest okay so you okay well i'll
explain in the most simple terms when
there's an ethereum trait when there's a
transaction ethereum there's a fee right
that's cool visa mastercard everybody
has a fee when you do a transaction
the ethereum fee gets broken into two
parts
there's the base fee which is just
burned so they take 70 percent of the
transaction fee
and they just get rid of it
why would you do that well this is like
when a when a company buys back stock
it's a share buyback they basically buy
stock on the open market and just get
rid of it what does that do it makes le
it shrinks the supply of the stock which
makes the price go up right there's less
supply but there's the same demand so
price goes up so so ethereum started
doing this thing last year where it
takes the fee and it just buys back
ethereum and gets rid of it which drives
the price of drives the supply down
price up okay cool that's the first bit
the second bit is there's like a tip
that's 30 of the fee uh today that goes
to miners but there's a like the way
ethereum there's like ethereum 2.0
coming out when it does that that's
going to go to the holders of ethereum
to the long-term holders of ethereum so
that's like a dividend being issued out
so now you have now ethereum has revenue
which last month that was 1.3 billion in
fees so real significant revenue
and we know that that go that accrues
the value accrues to the two holders of
ethereum so what price target did did he
put on it so he does a model he does a
discounted cash flow model and he
basically says based on this revenue
based on this multiple and based on the
this discount rate the price target for
ethereum right now right now the present
value of ethereum according according to
this model is ten thousand dollars per
each ether is trading at two point six
thousand
two point six k if you believe this
guy's model he's under value currently
by about four x and he put the model out
there so anybody can go change it you
can say name
uh his name is
google to read it what was his name ryan
alice
and um
and so you could say okay maybe he's got
really like aggressive assumptions in
his model um well actually he just used
the average price to earnings multiple
of the s p 500 um and he assumed 25
annual growth uh for the ethereum
message over the next 20 years which is
not like super aggressive right it grew
like a thousand percent last year 400
this year like you know it's growing
much faster than that right now so
you've used pretty conservative
estimates now there's always risks right
any i i have this phrase i put in my i
put in the newsletter this morning which
is that you know more fiction gets
written in excel than
in books um you know because uh you can
you can make a excel model dance and
make it look great just by tweaking two
little variables so you always have to
be careful with the stuff you got to do
your own homework but i found this to be
really interesting because the common
narrative is oh it's all speculation
it's got no intrinsic value there's no
fundamentals there's no analysis you can
do on it uh you're just guessing what
the next guy is going to buy and that
actually is true for most coins and it
was true for ethereum until now and one
of the best things you can do as an
investor is spot when something a common
narrative is now no longer true uh those
are usually pretty big opportunities so
anyways that was
i'm up till 3 a.m last night because i'm
learning what this guy's model looked
like i'm kind of checking it for myself
does this make sense to me and i'm
putting that in the newsletter it's like
hey let me make this simple for you to
understand like this is kind of cool
um
and so even though that's a lot of work
that's a prison of my own making that
i'm happy to do because i i would rather
you're going to be into this though for
years i think you will be um that's the
big tbd but that's the that's the i
think you will for now i'm into it i'm
providing a [__] out of value
nine months from now 28 months from now
am i gonna feel the same i don't know
but hopefully we can hire a writer who
doesn't feel the same i think with most
people even the [__] they love it does
get boring sometimes and then what you
do is you walk away or you chill and
then you you fall in love again i mean i
have to imagine that even
steven spielberg is like i don't want to
make a movie this year
right you know what i mean
uh i i think is that how they feel i
wonder what like nadal or what's what's
the tennis player or the uh um rafael
nadal yeah i wonder like what he thinks
about like tennis or something like that
i mean i like usain bolt was like i
don't even like training man i'm just
doing this because i'm good at it and it
like i i like winning but i don't really
love i'm not in love with this right now
um
and like that's normal i think that's
natural and you see even like fighters
like dustin poirier when he beat conor
mcgregor he was like man i'm over this i
don't even like doing this anymore i
don't even like this anymore tom brady
just retired yesterday right and he's
like basically he's one he's 44 now so
he's been doing this for like you know
20 plus years um professionally and he
was like football is he's like i still
love the games but football is a 365
days a year commitment for me i don't
know if you know about tom brady but he
like sleeps every day at like eight p.m
i mean he started like the t12 or
whatever his thing is called the tea
body or whatever his thing is called
wanting to come on the path
oh really his trainer yeah the guy alex
i don't know if his trainer or business
partner but like he branded himself as
the guy who started it
the tv12 method um
so uh yeah i think people do get burnt
out tony robbins has this thing he says
which he goes people's number one need
in life is certainty so like you need to
know where your next meal is coming if
you've got a roof over your head where
you're gonna sleep
that's why we love relationships because
we love the certainty and comfort of
knowing who's gonna be there who you
talk to what you do every day we love
routines he goes but you know god in her
infinite wisdom made it so that uh the
second biggest need we have is
uncertainty which is variety which is
it's like a see-saw what do you do as
soon as the thing is balanced you start
jumping around to mess it up right and
like you got to know that about your
nature and um
and there's like you know it's it's
completely normal to
enjoy a structured routine and then at
the same time crave variation doesn't
mean you don't like the thing or it's
not cool anymore
it's just that that's how humans are
wired all right sick let's wrap up here
because i've got i've got some stuff
that i wanted to cover but we didn't get
through today and so we'll save that for
monday right okay cool
producer ben what did you think of the
app
good episode uh
uh good episode ben levy good edition
good story uh yeah solid episode ben
your your meme was amazing he did this
meme which is like
walks into shaun's office for interview
is your name ben yes you're hired
we're putting together a team if your
name is ben and you're talented get it
get at us how's your uh what was your
what was your numbers in january
ben oh i need to look it up it was uh it
didn't beat my best month which was um
like just below 100. my best month was
97 or something like that and this was
just below that
what's the latest uh who are you
profiling right now what story are you
telling uh well i'm still in the middle
of walt disney i haven't put out part
two yet um
so i'm in the middle of that
also i'm i'm a bigamist i'm a cheater
when it comes to research so i'm also
doing a little research on other stuff
too yeah so i know a fair bit about walt
disney what's like give me one tidbit
that's like
bet you didn't know this or this is
super what i found super fast give me
one i haven't listened to that he's
optimistic and he went broke and
bankrupt a few times right
yeah i mean that was the most amazing
thing to me
um actually the tidbit that like has
blown my mind the most
um
is there's a story where
basically they're inventing cartoons
with sound and like they're showing it
to this audience
the audience is going crazy right so
they keep showing it to him again and
again and again and finally a couple of
his animators are like
we can't do this it's six hours they've
been showing it to him it's two in the
morning so they just like go outside of
the theater a little bit and they're
like smoking and talking and he comes
out and he goes
yeah what are you guys gonna do you
stand out here talking about babies or
you're gonna come inside and change the
world
and it blew my mind because i was like
if you just told me that that quote out
of context i would have told you it was
steve jobs like it was it's so similar
and then i just like started putting it
i would have thought of sampar when he
said uh do you want your kids to have
braces
[Laughter]
so those those are just like two stories
that i'm breaking this down now in the
second episode the similarities between
their stories are actually like kind of
uncanny they have a lot of weird
similarities yeah isn't it i've always
thought that like you could
with all types of people that you could
basically there's like i i was always
trying to think how many categories are
there of people because i remember
meeting some people i'm like oh you are
this you are exactly this human being
and after listening to your podcast i
remember listening to edison and i'm
like oh elon is exactly like that and if
i study edison i bet you i can like make
sense of a lot of what elon's doing and
help predict what he might do and i
wonder if you could do the same
for like a jobs and a uh
a walt disney where you just put them in
the same category like i can understand
a lot of stuff because of ben this is
perfect for your your uh consulting
business that you've created off the pod
you know those disc personality surveys
where it's like you're a dominant you
know indifferent or whatever you know
like some [__] like that you're a
red blue and you can get along with
greens uh you just need to do that with
like great great people in history it's
like you're 42 jobs and actually like
you know
you're 42 jobs and you're 60
um you know like whatever uh
you know walt disney and it's like what
does that mean it's like well
you're like jobs in this way and
everybody just gets a compliment it's
like oh yeah i'm 82 percent edison
actually and i don't work well with
disney's
i'm 32 percent wozniak i need to find my
job
yeah yeah do some like myers-briggs over
the top of it i like that um
i'm all about making up fake personality
uh quizzes i think that's great i gotta
run i gotta go get my workout in it's
about to snow and get freezing in austin
like the first time in a long time so i
gotta go doesn't austin like shut down
when it snows yeah it's stupid like last
year we were shut down for like a week
but i didn't have power in water for six
days and it was like 20 degrees so it
was kind of warranted by the way
speaking of one-liners you said an
amazing one after we recorded last week
uh like like he was just saying that
walt disney quote what was the one that
you said that our our buddy said he goes
remember the lime he goes and this guy's
like worth a hundred plus million
dollars he said um
people hate on get rich quick schemes
are they crazy getting rich quick is the
best way to get rich
why would anyone hate on that i love
getting rich
i only want to get rich quick yeah he
goes you got a good get rich quick
scheme for me i love that and this guy
like sold his company in like two years
so like it was a get-rich-quick scheme
it worked
that's so funny all right see you guys
[Music]
you